IT'S 5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
7 MINUTES INTO JOE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY AND THE BORDER IS
A DISASTER.
VIDEO SHOWS MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CRAMMED INTO A ROOM
AMID RISING COVID FEARS.
WE ARE GETTING STAGGERING NEW
NUMBERS.
212,000 MIGRANTS WERE
APPREHENDED IN JULY.
BREAKING A 20 YEAR RECORD.
THE NUMBERS WENT UP EVERY MONTH
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS SWORN
IN.
THE HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
MAYORKAS WAS AT THE BORDER TODAY
TRYING TO DOWN PLAY THE
SITUATION.
>> THE SITUATION AT THE BORDER
IS ONE OF THE TOUGHEST
CHALLENGES WE FACE.
WE HAVE SEEN SURGES IN MIGRATION
BEFORE.
THEY ARE NOT NEW.
>> WHILE BIDEN OFFICIALS CLAIM
THERE IS NOT A CRISIS, LOOK AT
THIS TEXAS JUDGE WHO DEALS WITH
THE SITUATION FIRSTHAND.
>> WE ARE ALL VERY, VERY
FRUSTRATED.
WHAT PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
THIS IS NOT JUST A BORDER
CRISIS.
IT'S A NATIONAL CRISIS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN FAILED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FAILING US
HERE ON THE BORDER.
WE ARE BATTLING A WAR AGAINST
THESE REFUGEES THAT ARE COMING
ILLEGALLY WITH OUR HANDS BEHIND
OUR BACK TIED.
NOT HAVING THE RESOURCES TO DO
THIS.
>> GREG, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> THANK YOU.
WHAT SHOULD I DO WITH IT?
IT'S REALLY DIRTY.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY AWFUL.
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH
"OUTNUMBERED" THEY LEAVE IT
A MESS.
>> THIS IS THE BEST EDUCATION
FOR THE VIEWER TO SEE HOW
CORPORATE MEDIA WORKS.
WHY DO THESE PHOTOS NOT MATTER?
WHY DOES THE SUFFERING NOT
MATTER?
THE MEDIA TEAM IS IN TOWN.
THE CORPORATE MEDIA TURNED EVERY
FACET OF LIFE INTO A TEAM SPORT
WHETHER IT'S THE BORDER OR COVID
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY FIND OUT WHAT SIDE THEY ARE
AGAINST AND PICK THE OTHER SIDE.
THAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
UNDER TRUMP, THE CONCERN ABOUT
KIDS IN CAGES WAS MERE THEATER
AND FALSE OUTRAGE.
YOU CAN CONTRAST THE DRAMATIC
CHANGES IN BEHAVIOR.
OUTRAGE UNDER TRUMP.
AMBIVALENT UNDER BIDEN.
IT'S NOT ABOUT IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S ABOUT OUR DISGUSTING DIRT
BAG MEDIA.
LIFE DOESN'T MATTER TO THEM.
POLITICS DOES.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THESE
PEOPLE.
AND THE MEDIA'S DEMONIC MOCKERY
OF UNMASKED AMERICANS AND
AMBIVALENCE TOWARDS ILLEGALS
STREAMING IN WHO DO HAVE COVID.
IS COVID REALLY THAT BAD IF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE FINE LETTING IN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE IT?
OF COURSE IT'S BAD.
THEY ARE LIKE A CRACK HEAD.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I AM THINKING ABOUT THAT.
TOTAL AGREE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLL NUMBERS
BIDEN HAS A 35% APPROVAL ON
IMMIGRATION.
57% DISAPPROVE.
MARTHA, IT'S ANYTHING THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS BEEN TETHERED TO THE
POLL NUMBERS.
MAYBE THIS IS THE BEST CHANCE
FOR THE COUNTRY TO HAVE SOME
SEMBLANCE OF THE ORDER AT THE
BORDER.
THEY REACT TO NOT THE SUFFERING,
KNOW THE CHILDREN PUT AT RISK,
NOT BEEN THE FENTANYL COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER BUT IT HURTS
PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE UPSET WITH
THEIR POLITICS.
>> THERE IS ANOTHER POLL THAT IS
INTERESTING.
THE INDEPENDENT BORDERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD APPROVAL ON
IMMIGRATION ISSUES AMONG
INDEPENDENT VOTERS AT 39%.
THAT'S HIGH.
BIDEN IS AT 31% WITH
INDEPENDENTS.
THOSE VOTERS WILL LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES IN 2022.
IT'S BEEN A ROUGH WEEK FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT AFGHANISTAN
IN A MOMENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT INFLATION AND
THE RISE OF COVID WITH THE DELTA
VARIANT AND WHAT IS REQUESTING
ON AT THE BORDER.
THERE IS A BIT OF WHACK A MOLE
GOING ON IN TERMS OF MANAGING
A CRISIS.
WHEN I LISTENED TO THE SECRETARY
AT THE BORDER.
HE SAID THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
THEN HE SAYS THE PROBLEM IS
212,000 PEOPLE CAME ACROSS THE
BORDER IN JULY.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE BORDER IS
NOT CLOSED.
IT'S CLEAR TO AMERICANS.
HE TALKS ABOUT HOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DISMANTLED THE
WHOLE SYSTEM AT THE BORDER.
HE IS REFERRING TO THE QUESTION
OF HOW THEY DEALT WITH
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
WE KNOW THE HISTORY ON THAT AND
KIDS IN CAGES.
IT WAS A DIFFICULT PERIOD IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THE FACT -- THEY HAVE TO REBUILD
IT HE IS SAYING.
WE ARE LETTING IN UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS.
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S A MORE HUMANE WAY TO DEAL
WITH CHILDREN TO BE ACCEPT GREAT
-- SEPARATED FROM PARENTS TO
COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
PEOPLE AT HOME ARE SCRATCHING
THEIR HEAD.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT SITUATION
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> WHERE IS KAMALA HARRIS?
SHE IN CHARGE OF BORDER CRISIS.
CLEARLY SHE'S DOING
A BLOCKBUSTER OF A JOB.
>> LOOK, THEY HAD STUMBLES OF
PRESENTATIONS FROM THE
VICE-PRESIDENT FOR SURE.
SHE HAS TRIED TO BACK AWAY AT
ANY RATE ISSUE.
I THINK -- ONE THING ABOUT THE
SURGE IS THAT IS COMPARING TO
THE YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC.
IF YOU COMPARE TO A NORMAL YEAR,
THIS SURGE IS NOT OUT OF THE
ORDINARY.
THERE IS AN ARTICLE IN THE TEXAS
TRIBUNE THAT SHOWED AT THE SAME
POINT THIS YEAR WITH 419,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
IN 2019 IT WAS 450,000.
IT IS COMPARABLE TO THAT.
THE ACHIEVEMENT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT REDUCING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
IT WAS REDUCING LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THEY CUT LEGAL IMMIGRANTS WANT
STUDENT VISAS BY MORE THAN 60%.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE COULD TALK ABOUT
THAT.
TALK ABOUT REFORMING
IMMIGRATION.
WE CAN'T WITHOUT BORDER
SECURITY.
1.20 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE COME
ACROSS THE BORDER.
19,000 KIDS.
YOU LET THE FIRST THOUSAND IN,
PEOPLE ARE SELLING THEIR HOUSE
TO GET THEIR CHILD TO GO WITH
A STRANGER TO GO THROUGH
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS TO GET TO
OUR COUNTRY.
THERE ARE NO WINNERS.
MAYORKAS KNOWS BETTER.
I BELIEVE MAYORKAS IS THE FALL
GUY WANT THE VICE-PRESIDENT
WON'T STEP UP.
THE VICE-PRESIDENT STEPPED BACK.
GREG, WE NEED YOU TO HOST "THE
FIVE."
I WILL STEP BACK.
THAT'S NOT AN OPTION.
THIS IS A DISASTER.
IT WAS PREVENTIBLE.
FOR JOE BIDEN TO BE IN DELAWARE
AND HIDING OUT ON VACATION AND
THE BORDER COMING TO IT PIECES
IS INEXCUSABLE.
>> ONE QUESTION, GREG GUTFELD,
WHO WAS THE 35% OF THE PEOPLE
POLLED WHO THINK THAT
IMMIGRATION AND THE BORDER
CRISIS IS OKAY?
WHO APPROVE OF IT.
WHO WERE THOSE PEOPLE?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
IN EVERY POLL THERE IS BETWEEN
25 TO 35% IDIOTS.
>> CRACK HEAD IDIOTS.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD HAVE A BORDER.
IT'S NOT RIGHT FOR TO US HAVE
A BORDER.
>> NO HOMELAND SECURITY AND NO
PROTECTION.
>> THEY CAN TALK TO THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LOST RELATIVES TO DRUG
OVERDOSES UP 30% IN 2020.
TALK TO THOSE PEOPLE OR ANYBODY
WHO I